foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday October 27th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
apple has a problem legislators in the
European Union approved new rules this
month that will force the makers of
portable electronic devices like
smartphones and laptops to equip them
with a USBC charging port the aim is to
have a common charging standard but
Apple's iPhones use its own lightning
charging port so what do the new rules
mean for the future of iPhones around
the globe at the Wall Street journals
Tech live conference this week wsj
senior personal Tech columnist Joanna
Stern put that question and more to
Apple's senior vice president of
software engineering Craig federighi and
Apple's senior vice president of
worldwide marketing Greg joswiak here
are highlights from their conversation
I've called you both here to talk about
really a big problem it's really it's a
global crisis at this point and I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring it up here
we're gonna start with you jaws what do
you what do you see when you look at
this I see two really cool connectors
yeah kind of the two most popular
connectors in the world I think right
now okay yeah
Craig I know you're a software guy but
what do you see
I gotta really agree with Jaws on this
one oh yeah great connectors two great
connectors okay I see a little bit of a
mess and so I'll tell you right so this
charges the iPhone now this charges the
mac and iPad and various other products
around the world
and so that's creating a little bit of
friction in fact the EU has approved
legislation to create a common charger
in fact they said in a press release in
2024 a USBC Port will become mandatory
for a whole range of electronic devices
such as mobile phones tablets and
headphones is Apple moving to USBC well
maybe I can step back a little bit
you may uh
you've probably heard me say for years
that I
don't mind governments telling us what
they want to accomplish but usually
we've got some pretty smart Engineers to
figure out the best ways to accomplish
them technically and
an example of that that I love to give
is for years and years mobile phones had
to satisfy a hearing aid compatibility
spec
very prescriptively described by you
know regulation that said here's what
you have to do to be compatible with
hearing aids the problem is it didn't
work
but all of us had to do it
and so we came up with a new way of
doing hearing aids made for iPhone so
what we were accomplishing is what the
government wanted what we did in a way
that worked better
and you know we've been in an argument
over this one for well over 10 years
and over 10 years ago the push
from the EU look they're well-meaning I
get you know I get the fact that they
want to accomplish a good thing what's
to do my career USB
and standardized as a micro speed and so
we have been in this little bit of a
disagreement and but part of what of
course they wanted to accomplish is why
should people have all these different
power adapters so we got to what we
think was a better place right which is
power adapters that had detachable
cables you know but all of them usb-a or
USBC and largely moving USBC but you
choose the cable you know that was
appropriate for your device whether
that's one of ours or somebody else's
and so we preferred that path uh
governments you don't get to do what
they're going to do and obviously we'll
have to comply but you know we think the
approach would have been better
environmentally and better for our
customers to to not have a government be
that prescriptive we're going to move to
privacy so back in 2021 You released app
tracking transparency or ATT and it gave
users more Choice over sharing their
data with other companies we have these
tiny pop-ups all coming up on our phones
right a big big business impact right
knocks billions in Revenue off of
companies like meta Google others did
you anticipate this domino effect I'd
say we we couldn't be sure uh I think we
were
truly just focused on doing the right
thing we'd been working for so many
years to try to bring more transparency
and control to so many areas of
experience and years before we brought
intelligent tracking prevention to
Safari and so we we'd seen the problem
of tracking on the web and we'd been
able to counter it to in large part and
we felt the world of apps should be no
different and you know I think there was
uncertainty about what the short-term
impact would be I think we felt in the
long term that quality advertising and
privacy could coexist there would be
Innovation some of it from us some of it
from others but that Journey had to
start it's a simple question Joanna and
it's just getting the user to say yeah
that's okay I mean how many times have
you shopped for something and all of a
sudden you are now getting emails from
other you know shoe companies when you
buy shoes or you're seeing you know web
ads everywhere
sometimes that creeps people out and
sometimes it's not as simple as shoes
right and as you know data Brokers are
building profiles on you you know based
on what can be sent to them that you
have no idea so all we're saying is look
advertising is cool just get the user's
permission if you're going to send it to
other companies there's been this
feeling though that a little bit of the
move has been hypocritical as there are
reports that Apple wants to move more
into advertising is that any part of the
motivation is Apple have well I should I
should say first
Zero part of the motivation this was
driven by our privacy team as part of a
long agenda that you could watch in
Apple's business year after year after
year how we were stepping up privacy
Protections in area after area this was
our team going you know we feel
protecting apps consistent with what
we've done Safari makes sense
we brought this to business and just
said heads up everyone you know what
you're doing this year after your
privacy agenda here's what's coming that
is where this feature came from Full
Stop
and by the way again just to clarify
we're not against advertising and by the
way we're hearing by all the same rules
right we're not sending any of your
information you know to anybody without
your permission as a matter of fact we
don't set it period and we give you
options to even opt out of what we're
keeping within you mean in your own app
in our own apps yeah okay well we're
gonna end there but I wanted to thank
you guys so much for coming we really
appreciate it thank you thank you guys
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more coverage of this
year's Tech live conference visit our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]